another central figure in the special
council probe is being accused of
sharing information with an associate
who may have ties to Russian
intelligence chief intelligence
correspondent catherine herridge has the
latest on that tonight new trouble for
Paul Manafort and the unusual way we
found out about it today good evening
Catherine
that's right Brennan good evening a
glitch in the court filing allowed the
redacted portions to be read revealing
that the Special Counsel has alleged
Paul Manafort reached out to a business
associate ensured pulling data related
to the 2016 election the business
associate konstantin : ik is widely
described as a russian ukrainian
political consultant and suspected
intelligence operative Kaleem nick has
previously denied ties to russian
intelligence
today's court filings by Manta force
legal team led by Kevin downing response
to special counsel allegations that the
former Trump campaign chairman lied to
federal investigators violating his plea
agreement Manta fourth lawyers report
their client is suffering from
depression anxiety and at times uses a
wheelchair adding prison conditions
weigh heavily on his state of mind and
memory the told the court man afford
often does not have the chance to review
records and refresh his memory before
meeting with special counsel
investigators his fair to say the
mistakes and failed recollections are
common between the government and
cooperating witnesses they write notably
there is no identifiable pattern to mr.
man affairs purported misrepresentations
no specific individual or potential
crime is identified defense lawyers are
not asking for an immediate hearing they
say special counsel claims the man Ford
lied can be addressed during the pre
sentencing process
Menna Ford is scheduled to be sentenced
in coming weeks in two separate
prosecutions Brett following all
Catherine thanks